on passe maintenant à notre terrien du
samedi 20h
[Musique]
alors Patrick vient l'annexe rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 9 octobre 1970 à Fréjus
dans le Var père attaché commercial au
Crédit Agricole mère artiste peintre la
famille vit à Saint-Raphaël
votre mère peint beaucoup elle expose
dans les galeries de la région les
enfants vous et vos soeurs participez à
la vente des tableaux vous êtes très
impliqué là-dedans
que j'ai commencé à dire tiens les
autres enfants étaient plus grands et
commencer à avoir d'autres
occupations et là j'ai dit je m'en
occuper ouais les derniers sages tout ça
je l'aide alors avec votre mère vous
visitez les expositions de la région et
vous prenez conscience de la de la
beauté du geste de la du coup de pinceau
du coup de pinceau c'est magnifique
alors votre père lui c'est un homme
d'ordre et de foi qui vous inculque les
principes de l'obéissance et l'amour de
Dieu et le respect mais votre père cache
un secret en fait il a été opéré du
coeur
parmi les tous premières on lui a posé
une valve mécanique
c'était ce qui se passait à l'époque et
la valve mécanique dans son cœur est
particulièrement bruyante et la famille
vit au rythme de ce tic-tac obsédant
c'est à dire que même quand il dort on
entend tic-tac ouais deux chambres à
côté les portes fermées en entrant des
le cœur battre quoi et cette peur
toujours de l'entendre ne plus battre
quoi alors vous êtes un petit garçon
discret poli
doux sur ton rêveur au fond de la classe
et sinon vous jouez au foot alors vous
avez 12 ans 182 lorsqu’un jour après un
match Draguignan vous allez avec votre
maman visiter le musée de Draguignan et
là vous découvrez le joyau de l'endroit
à rembrand l'enfant à la bulle de savon
voilà c'est deux choses vous fascine là
dedans la tristesse dans le regard
portant
c'est un enfant sympathique mais dans le
regard il est triste et puis vous voyez
une
correspondance disons entre le tic-tac
du cœur de votre père qui peut s'arrêter
et la bulle de savon qui peut exploser
donc pour vous c'est un peu un miroir ce
tableau c'est la bulle de savon pour moi
ça a été l'effet mérité du temps donc la
fugacité et tout ça
mon père mon père alors les années
suivantes le tableau de rembrand
continue à vous obséder et un jour à
l'âge de 17 ans vous retournez à
Draguignan pour un problème de carte
grise de moto et là vous en profitez
pour aller au musée et revoir l'enfant à
la bulle de savon et là vous commencez à
développer avec lui une véritable
relation vous essayez de le consoler
pour vous consoler vous-même ça
ressemble un peu à une confession quoi
vous lui parlez on sait qu'on fait c'est
tous les deux oui il y a une confession
de ma part une confession de sa peur je
vous obsède je l'observe et il m'observe
alors à 18 ans un BEP en poche vous
enchaînez les petites Jobs mais mais
rien ne vous plaît vous avez vous êtes
un peu perdu hein à l'adolescence
complètement complètement je cherchais
une voix
alors vous avez 24 ans quand le cœur de
votre père s'arrête
il est incinéré à Draguignan ce qui vous
incite à aller revoir le tableau une
semaine plus tard
et là c'est toujours la même émotion que
vous voyez ce tableau
plus intense plus intense il me manque
quelque chose je l'ai retrouvé dans
l'enfant
alors après le décès de votre père vous
quittez le foyer familial vous suivez
des formations vous devenez pendant
quatre ans technicien dans le domaine
des alarmes
en 1999 vous avez donc 29 ans vous
retrouvez de nouveau à la préfecture de
Draguignan et pour la quatrième fois de
votre vie vous passez au musée voir
l'enfant à la bulle de savon et là le
déclic se produit vous vous dites il
faut que je le ramène chez moi à ce truc
là je peux le faire vous avez un
objectif dans la vie cette fois c'est de
ramener ce tableau chez vous ma passion
et de faire quelque chose de ma passion
alors en tant que technicien d'alarme
évidemment vous connaissez tout sur les
sur les détecteurs les lasers et puis
surtout vous savez les délais
d'intervention de la sécurité 10 minutes
donc vous dites c'est jouable
le 13 juillet 1999 vous arrivez à
Draguignan à 14h prendre un verre et à
15h vous entrez au musée et là vous
planquez dans une armoire normande que
vous aviez repéré alors vous restez 5
heures là non 5 6 heures une chaleur
étouffante en plus
à 21h vous sortez de votre cachette
et vous savez qu'à 22h parce qu'on est
le 13 juillet donc la veille du 14
juillet il y aura une parade militaire
d'hélicoptère qui va couvrir le bruit de
la larme en fait
et là bon vous faites un cas c'est top
Cappy quoi
vous savez quand l'alarme va se
déclencher tout voilà et vous ressortez
avec le rembrand
dans un sac poubelle c'est ça c'est
incroyable quand vous rentrez chez vous
vous êtes un surhomme je suis assurant
vous êtes Arsène Lupin quoi
dans ma tête à ce moment-là
et vous faites un polaroid un selfie on
le voit là
debout chez vous avec Laurent brun en
arrivant chez vous c'est incroyable quoi
et puis vers 3h du matin le fou rire
retombe
la joie laisse place à la paranoïa et
vous commencez à attendre les flics avec
des sueurs froides de long de la nuque
et là je me suis posé sur le lit et je
dis bon je vais attendre c'est pas
possible j'ai dû rater quelque chose
j'avais laissé quelques poils dans la
vitre que j'avais cassé les jours
suivants la presse parle d'empreinte
retrouver et de cheveux du voleur alors
là vous vous dites toute ma vie je vais
fuir les flics quoi en gros vous
emballez le rembrand et vous glissez
sous le lit là ça commence ça commence à
à partir de là ce tableau va prendre le
contrôle de votre vie malgré votre
rencontre avec Christelle que vous
épouserez ça ne suffit pas vous calmer
non ça c'est accentué parce que vous le
contemplez pendant des heures ça
arrivait avec un petit Sauterne
[Musique]
en face des magnifiques
alors votre femme elle voit ça
on pourrait penser qu'elle s'inquiète en
fait non c'est un portrait de mon père
un portrait de mon père fait par ma mère
voilà bah oui
c'est extraordinaire alors vous
commencez à déménager toujours guidé par
le bien-être du tableau
un jour vous êtes cambriolé vous habitez
à Grasse vous êtes cambriolé alors là
vous êtes fous et puis heureusement les
mecs ils ont pas vu le Rembrandt ils ont
pris ils ont pris la chaîne hi-fi
à vous déménager encore la fois d'après
c'est les termites on vous redéménagez
carrément dingue c'est l'humidité il
sait il va pourrir le tableau donc il
faut déménager et votre femme lui
expliquer comment à chaque fois qu'il
faut déménager oh ça me plaît pas les
maisons me plaisent pas on y croit
isolés j'ai trouvé toujours une excuse
après vous allez dans les Landes alors
dans les Landes vous avez peur de
l'incendie oui et début 2014 vous
décidez quand même de vous débarrasser
du tableau et là vous avez un pote qui
s'appelle Tony
Tony connaît des gens un peu ouais alors
Tony vous organise un rendez-vous avec
des assureurs est-ce que vous savez que
quand on rentre le tableau les assureurs
vous donnent un petit quelque chose bon
je vais rendre le tableau c'est fini
cette histoire etc en échange d'un
chèque de 40000 euros vous repartez avec
votre chèque il y a quelque chose vous
choque quand même vous dites quand même
cette assureur il est bizarre il m'a
servi du jus de fruit dans un verre à
Bourgogne c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est
pas banal et puis vous dites il
m'inspire pas confiance cette assureur
il ressemble à Arnaud Montebourg
j'en sors pas par fier de cette
assurance
quelques jours plus tard vous apprenez
que l'assureur a été arrêtée
en essayant de revendre le tableau en
fait
et là il fallait que j'appelle ma femme
pour lui expliquer la vérité
pour moi le on va dire le voyage de ces
jours en prison est obligatoire
donc je vais l'appeler à 10h30 elle
arrivait à 11h
là j'ai commencé à lui expliquer j'ai
fait voilà ça s'est passé il y a 15 ans
je suis l'auteur du vol là les sanglots
ça a été les sanglots mais de l'autre
côté
elle dit ça fait des années que tu me
racontes des conneries tu me dis que
c'est un tableau de ton père parle ta
mère ça ouais
et ça pas été une cause de rupture
apparemment ça resserrait le lien
le tableau en fait Laurent brun il vaut
4 millions d'euros
donc vous êtes très en toute la France
avec votre truc emballé dans du papier
journal ça valait jusqu'à 4 millions
d'euros hein alors vous vous dites ça y
est quoi je vais y passer je vais aller
en tôle et il y a un piano dans cette
histoire il y a prescription ouais les
vols c'est 10 ans c'est 10 ans voilà
donc 15 ans c'est bon mais je ne savais
pas
pensé ouais vous étiez sûr de l'entoule
à certains j'avais fait mon sac tout
était prêt je suis arrivé chez mon
avocat avec les affaires
et quand le chalet partir en prison pour
moi c'était certain voilà alors
aujourd'hui vous voulez devenir gardien
de musée c'est ça
j'aimerais bien ouais j'aimerais bien je
sais qu'il aura accroche au tableau le
14 le 13 juillet mais il n'a pas invité
ah ils vous ont pas invité
avec le soin vous avez pris de ce
tableau pendant toutes ces années
et est-ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez récidiver
dans un moment de solitude
dans les musées on va dire pas les
dans les anciens musées il y a beaucoup
de lacunes en sécurité
oui travailler dans un journal d'art
peut-être oui mais j'ai commencé à
monter une page Facebook où j'ai
beaucoup de visites justement sur l'art
et l'heure de Rembrandt et là en général
qui marche pas
je suis content
c'est une histoire extraordinaire quel
moral vous tirez de cette histoire
qu'il a retrouvé il a retrouvé sa maison
et cette parade
et la bulle n'a toujours pas explosé et
la vie n'a toujours pas explosé merci de
votre témoignage et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu